các lòng chiến lánh đạo đầm, nhanh lúc và quanh kể nghiên zân
theo giỏi các lực lượng bố chăng nếu bình trên biển
tại thân cứu quân sự câm ra khánh hoa.
Càng định sức mạnh làm cho bố biển không chơi,
được nếu on thuyền thô sương ngày đầu thành lập.
Các lực lượng bố chăng trên biển đặc bố nguyên mình lướng mạnh
tính hàng lên hiện đại.
Các biển đội tâu chiến tông ẩm tối tân,
có thản nhanh bắt chiến đại ngày trong mọi yếu kiện thời thiết,
được chân bị hình lượng nếu lỗi bố kiến tông nghệ cao
có sức tông phát mạnh, dân bánh xa, tính tông bàn bố kiến,
điều diệt hiệu quả hát mục tiêu chiến bộ chiến không trên biển
và hát mục tiêu mầm.
Để lật lượng lòng cố,
là lá tránh thích bố chắc,
nếu đau sống bao viên chủ khuyền biển đạo,
xe mục biển khiến liên của tố cố.
Tất đồng chiến đạo đàn,
nhà nước, vặt quan tế nhân dân,
khiếp tục theo doi diếu bình của các lực lượng ố chân trên biển.
Tông tăng sự phản của tất tộc,
lực lượng bố chân trên biển,
mạnh mắm có, là hai quan nhân dân biển nắm án hồn,
đã lập nên những chiến công băng rồi,
viết nên con được huyệt hoài,
lượng hồ chi Minh trên biển.
Bán chiếc, và lòng qua cảm ố sống,
hả bám vẻ trần không qua,
những chiến tâm mừng chiến tranh thảo hoài của kẻ thù.
Bằng những cuộc khánh quan thần tóc,
tạo bảo,
đắt lực lượng đã trải phòng các đạo,
và cuộc đạo chiếm xa tiến liên,
lấp quan quan trọng,
và lại thẳng mùa xuân nắm bộ gàn chiến tranh bảo lắm,
của nó sống về một mối,
và quan thành hoặc sắc về buộc quốc để cao cả.
Tại vì thực oi đây,
cũng là lần đầu tiên lực lượng hải quân dự quyền trên biển,
các cuộc ra.
Nhết địa chào mừng thắp lực lượng vũ chăm trên biển,
những người không ứng tụi của tổ quốc nơi đầu sống lộ gió.
Bước vào thời tiên xin dừng vào vệ tổ quốc,
thắp lực lượng vũ chăm trên biển không ứng lắm chủ vũi,
chăm bị hiện đại.
Chờ thành là hát chẳng tếp biển cường,
bảo vệ vũ chắc,
bình khúc đau, sản biển, biển,
biển, mối con tổ,
mối người liển là một cuộc mất trục về tổ,
này điên tốn chân tăng á,
sáng tăng lập tăng mở ở mua,
hành động sống thạc của kẻ cửa.
Hát đồng chiến còn là điểm từ trong lươn buôn hơi bắn biển.
Hổ phần xây dừng tế chật quốc vào toàn tân trên biển,
buốn chắc,
hết thực oan khác bảo,
như Việt Nam chờ thành quốc ra,
mang về biển,
dâu tuyền.
Chào mừng khác lực lượng,
ô trăng,
đang dũng viên chè biển.
Chúc yêu cầu như bố trong tình hiểm mở.
Hát lực lượng,
ô trăng trên biển,
không cần dành viển.
Sây dừng theo hình,
hết mạng,
chính quyền,
tình về,
e Đài.
Hồi là lực lượng tiến phòng,
nơi tuyên đau,
lúc nư dân quân khơi bắn biển.
Hồi là lạch thẳng tiếp,
rử vấn mối chường hà bình.
Măng chăm tình lời tế thắc sôn
toàn lối chung thành với đảm.
Thôi,
và yên dân,
mối người liên biển hôm nay,
sẵn sàng chiến đau,
khi xin,
mạo về vấn chắc chùu quyền Việt dạo,
trong mọi tình hồn,
quân quan ra tạo,
sư tin,
tiến vào kiến bên mởi,
kiến quyền của một Việt Nam,
quân,
thích bật,
học kì,
tất tiến vào Lệ Đài.